et maintenant c'est l'heure du meilleur
d'eux guillon 2010 c'est
le journal libération elle par les
techniques de défense utilisée par
françois fillon à celle des meurtriers
dans la série columbo c'est vrai qu'il
ya des similitudes
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur fillon
au début de votre campagne lorsque
pénélope a été accusée d'emplois fictifs
vous aviez promis d'apporter les preuves
de son travail or aujourd'hui deux mois
plus tard toujours rien pas le moindre
signe d'activité même à sablé sur sarthe
où elle était censée vous remplacez
personne ne connaît son visage
mais vous ma femme qui est mère au foyer
comme la vôtre et est un merveilleux
cordons bleus ne touchent aucun salaire
pour ça
jamais le comté du sheriff ne lui a
versé le moindre centime pas une
cacahuète et pourtant elle fait les
bancs des comédies comme personne
je vous laisse je connais la sortie
dernière chose tu fillon
c'est idiot mais j'aimerais savoir
comment vous faites pour avoir des
costumes toujours impeccable
moi j'ai beau les accroches il est
vendre précis qui sont toujours froissé
arnys
vous allez à la boutique avis
je me disais qu'il y avait un truc et
sites web suffit
ça doit coûter un bar un costume de
cette qualité
jeunes vous dérange plus jeu je connais
la sortie
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron assure avoir trouvé des
convergences avec merkel macro et
trouvent des convergences avec tout le
monde de robert hue alain madelin ça
pourrait devenir une couleur le
maquereau vois un truc qui va avec tout
ça je sais pas quoi mettre dans la
cuisine ja du bordeaux du verre du
orange mais du maquereau le maquereau tu
peux pas te tromper ça va avec tout ou
un plat ça pourrait devenir un plat le
maquereau à je sais pas je sais pas quoi
manger je suis ballonné j'ai envie de
rien prend du maquereau ça va avec tout
sucré salé viandes poissons plats en
sauce ça n'a aucun goût mais ça passe
tout seul
international donald trump déclare le
mois d'avril mois officiel de prévention
des agressions sexuelles donc au mois
d'avril on ne peut plus attraper les
femmes par la chatte you can all angoua
brou mbaye de pussy après oui après
partir du mois de mai on met en fait ce
qu'on veut fait ce qu'il te plaît donald
reprendra ses bonnes habitudes à la trup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
télévision on a beaucoup parlé cette
semaine du grand retour de pierre menez
au canal le football club mais il y
avait aussi celui de mimie mathy qui a
également subi une lourde opération
je repars pour 20 ans annonce la
comédienne
bon autant les progrès de la médecine
quand c'est pour bien menez on est
content mais là vingt ans de joséphine
ange gardien supplémentaire
ça fait un peu chier
nicolas sarkozy surpris par un policier
alors qu'il faisait du vélo en sens
interdit sur le port de saint-tropez
l'officier de police lui a demandé de
descendre et de continuer à pied
franchement thierry ardisson c'est de
l'acharnement
à l'heure j'ai en vacances en famille
que je suis plus candidat à la
présidentielle on vient m'arrêter me
demander de descendre avec un peu de
chance on va me demander la facture du
vélo avec quel argent je les achetais
10000euros lé cadre en carbone c'est
martine aubry qui me l'a offert un c'est
pas la vie bettencourt sais pas monsieur
takieddine c'est martin on va aussi
contre les mesures il me faire pisser
dans un bocal me déclaré positif sous
prétexte que j'ai mis 10 minutes pour
relier le cap [ __ ] à saint tropez j'ai
triché je suis le lance amstrong de la
politique comme le laisse faire du vélo
thierry ardisson comme n'importe quel
retraités faire des mots fléchés et
relire la princesse de clèves je n'en
demande pas plus à l'espagne
mais stéphane bilan entre les six la
semaine bretonne et d'ici là sur ces 8
point fr et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu